Події останніх місяців відчутно позначилися на уряді Німеччини.
Коаліція мало не розвалилася, з проявами насильства
та ненависті у ФРН пройшли протести,
а очільника Федерального відомства з охорони Конституції
звинуватили у покриванні правих радикалів.
Мій гість цього тижня у Страсбурзі - Девід Макаллістер.
Він голова комітету із зовнішньої політики Європарламенту
й екс-прем'єр однієї з федеральних земель Німеччини.
Можливо, Анґелі Меркель час на вихід?
Девіде Макаллістере, ласкаво просимо у Conflict Zone.
Давайте поговоримо спершу про мігрантів. Ситуація покращилася -
у Німеччину приїжджає менше біженців, як і в інші країни ЄС.
Але наслідки цієї кризи фактично вбивають партію Меркель
ХДС та й весь уряд, чи не так?
Ця тема не вбиває мою партію.
Це питання ... це .... головний виклик для Німеччини
і всього Європейського Союзу.
Число прибулих ... зменшилося порівняно з 2015 роком.
Але ми повинні подбати про те, щоб це число не збільшувалося.
Тобто нам у Європейському Союзі не слід забувати,
що в Європі і в Шенгенській зоні, де немає контролю на кордонах,
наша зовнішня межа - це європейська зовнішня межа ...
... і ми повинні її краще захищати.
... так, але ви кажете, це не вбиває вас.
Влітку правляча коаліція майже розпалася, чи не так?
Були постійні суперечки через біженців,
через насильство з боку праворадикалів.
Соціал-демократична партія, а саме її генеральний секретар Ларс Клінґбайль,
назвав це станом постійної кризи.
Тож, це все вбиває вашу партію.
Безумовно, ми у Німеччині пережили кілька бурхливих тижнів і місяців.
Я радий, що коаліційні партії - ХДС, ХСС і соціал-демократи -
тепер погодилися зосередитися на цих питаннях,
і це саме те, чого очікують громадяни Німеччини від уряду ...
Ви нашвидкуруч досягли компромісу. Більше нічого, чи не так?
Я маю на увазі, що фактично крайня права партія
"Альтернатива для Німеччини" має досить сильні і стабільні позиції, чи не так?
Коли займаєшся політикою, завжди слід бути готовим до компромісу.
А якщо ви в коаліційному уряді трьох партій,
то доводиться також бути готовим укладати угоди і знаходити компроміси.
Я бачу, ви ігноруєте те, що я сказав про AдН.
... але в цьому полягає щоденна робота уряду.
AдН зростає. Її позиції сильні. Вона стабільна.
За деякими опитуваннями, вона на другому місці за популярністю у Німеччині.
Так, і, без сумніву, це тривожна тенденція...
Місяць тому ви не надавали цьому значення. Ви сказали, що загроза AдН
вас не турбує, бо 85 відсотків німців не голосують за праворадикалів.
Ну, навіть 15 відсотків для AдН в опитуваннях -
для мене це забагато. І я б хотів,
щоб ці цифри зменшилися і дійсно вважаю, що без AдН…
Вони диктують порядок денний. Вони нав'язують дискусію про мігрантів.
Той факт, що тільки 15 відсотків німців проголосували за них,
не грає абсолютно жодної ролі. Вони диктують порядок денний, чи не так?
Ні, не диктують.
Люди з АдН дають прості, дуже прості, я б навіть сказав, примітивні відповіді
на дуже складні питання. Ми повинні чітко розуміти,
що політика - це щось більше, ніж спрощені відповіді.
Потрібно багато працювати. Тому я радий, що уряд
нарешті вирішив повернутися до роботи
і сконцентруватися на серйозних питаннях.
Нам потрібно уникати внутрішньопартійної боротьби,
а також протистояння всередині коаліції.
Пошук компромісів - це нормально,
але те, що ми спостерігали останні кілька тижнів, не було конструктивним,
і єдина партія, яка від цього виграла, це АдН - тут ви маєте рацію.
Тому що краще ми будемо працювати,
тим імовірніше, що популярність AдН піде на спад.
Ну, поки ви шукаєте складні відповіді,
мільйони виборців ХДС/ХСС перейшли на бік AдН.
Тобто справи у вас йдуть не дуже добре, чи не так?
Якщо в AдН, згідно з опитуваннями, зараз десь 16-17 відсотків голосів виборців,
то очевидно одне: вони відбирають голоси у всіх партій.
Так, до них пішли і наші виборці. Але і сотні тисяч людей,
які раніше голосували за соціал-демократів,
тепер готові віддати свій голос AдН.
Як ви оцінюєте нинішню ситуацію з канцлеркою Анґелою Меркель,
яка дедалі більше нагадує поранену тварину.
Вона втратила ключового соратника після того, як парламентарії
не проголосували за людину, яку Меркель запропонувала на пост
глави фракції у Бундестазі...
Це не несподіванка. Це серйозна поразка для неї особисто, чи не так?
Ну, Анґела Меркель і сама сказала, що це поразка. В умовах демократії таке трапляється.
У вас не вийде видати це за успіх.
Але я намагаюся ...
Це поразка для неї. Як сказав єврокомісар з питань бюджету Ґюнтер Еттінґер,
вона тепер кульгава качка. Він так і сказав: кульгава качка.
Анґела Меркель - канцлерка Федеративної Республіки Німеччина. Вона ...
…вразлива, вкрай вразлива канцлерка.
Ймовірно, вона знову буде балотуватися на пост голови партії ХДС
на партійному з'їзді на початку грудня. І я б підтримав її ...
Один високопосадовць ХДС днями сказав Financial Times:
я допускаю, що все вище керівництво партії буде змушене піти у відставку,
зокрема і Меркель. Тож, навколо неї у ХДС збираються хмари, чи не так?
Ми вирішили спершу зосередитися на регіональних виборах у Баварії і Гессені.
А тоді подивимося. Те, що показують опитування ...
звичайно, на більш низькому рівні, але попри це,
ХДС у Гессені і ХСС у Баварії як і раніше посідають лідируючі позиції.
І, ймовірно, ми знову очолимо уряди в цих двох федеральних землях...
Але, звичайно, нам знадобляться партнери по коаліції.
Ви знаєте, ми пережили бурхливі тижні у німецькій політиці.
Її успішність вичерпується, чи не так?
Сила йде від неї. У неї більше немає енергії.
Вона виглядає вразливою. Вона виглядає слабкою.
Вона більше не може диктувати свою волю всередині партії.
За її соратників не голосують.
Не знаю, як в інших країнах, але для Німеччини
у таких злетах і падіннях у політиці немає нічого особливого.
Звичайно, я б хотів, щоб нині результати опитувань були кращими,
але впевнений, що ми повернемося на колишні позиції.
І тоді рівень нашої підтримки серед населення знову зросте.
Ви говорите про корупцію в інших країнах, але ЄС, як можна помітити,
не впорався навіть зі своєю власною корупцією.
Ганебна правда про Європу в тому,
що вона аж ніяк не така прозора і чесна, якою любить себе зображувати.
Погляньте на банківські скандали цього року!
30 мільярдів доларів росіян і мешканців країн колишнього СРСР
відмивалися через естонське відділення ... датського банку.
Нідерландський банк Ай-Ен-Джі
змусили заплатити 775 мільйонів євро.
Латвійський банк закрили,
тому що через нього фінансувалася ядерна програма Північної Кореї.
Тож, люди використовують ці жахливі лазівки,
які досі існують у європейській банківській системі.
Чому ви допустили ці лазівки?
Дивіться, я не відповідаю за лазівки в європейській банківській системі.
Приклади, які ви навели ...
Ви високопоставлений член Європарламенту…
Так, звичайно, але наведені приклади некоректні.
Ухвалювати рішення про закриття цих лазівок повинні уряди тих чи інших країн,
а також певні європейські структури ...
А ви знаєте, скільки співробітників Європейського банківського управління,
які займаються проблемою відмивання грошей, працюють на повну ставку?
Я буду радий дізнатися це від вас.
Дві. Дві людини.
Дві людини?
Ці двоє працюють на повну ставку. Це ж несерйозно.
Це ж найчистіше потурання всередині Європейського союзу,
що стосується відмивання грошей.
Я не можу це прокоментувати, але ще раз перевірю ці цифри.
Припускаю, що є люди і в окремих країнах, які також за це відповідають,
але я не хочу зараз нікого захищати. Відмивання грошей -
серйозне правопорушення і, звичайно, Європейський союз і країни-члени ЄС
повинні докласти всіх зусиль, щоб таке не повторювалося.
Пане Макаллістере, наявність стандартів не допоможе, якщо європейські судді
дозволяють депутатам, таким як ви,   приховувати подробиці
своїх витрат замість того, щоб показувати іншим приклад прозорості.
Нещодавно Європейський суд вирішив, що докладне інформування громадськості
про витрати означало б вторгнення в особисте життя депутата Європарламенту.
Депутати це робити не зобов'язані.
Ну, це дискусія ...
У чому сенс? Тут вам все може зійти з рук, чи не так?
Ця постанова Європейського суду. Це дискусія, яка ...
яку ми ведемо в цьому Європейському парламенті вже кілька років.
У країн-членів ЄС різні стандарти.
У деяких країнах депутати зобов'язані розкривати кожну деталь
своїх щомісячних виплат. В інших країнах інший порядок.
4416 євро загальних витрат, за які депутату не треба звітувати.
Це гроші платників податків.
Як щодо права людей знати?
Якщо чесно, особисто для мене не було б проблемою, якби правила змінили.
Але на даний момент ситуація така.
Це питання, яке має вирішуватися на рівні ради міністрів і президента.
І я б дотримався... Я дотримаюсь норм, ухвалених з цього питання.
Але рішення, яке вже прийнято, сприяє марнотратству і шахрайству. Чи не так?
Ні.
Це крок назад для Європейського союзу, який оспівує свої цінності
в усьому світі, а потім дозволяє людям
не звітувати ... Мова про підзвітність, чи не так?
Так.
Це звичайна підзвітність, і її ігнорують?
Так, але якщо я правильно поінформований, у парламенті Німеччини дуже схожа ситуація.
І я жодного разу не чув, щоб депутати Бундестагу
не несли відповідальність за те, що вони роблять.
Вони отримують зарплату кожен місяць,
і ці гроші вони можуть витратити на свій кабінет, на газети, книги ...
Питання в тому, чи потрібно фіксувати ці витрати.
Якщо ми почнемо це документувати,
якщо це буде вирішено, я це точно буду робити,
то це призведе до ще більшої бюрократії.
Хтось повинен буде контролювати, на що витрачалися гроші,
чи достовірні ці цифри...
Добре, закінчимо на цьому. Девіде Макаллістере,
дякую за інтерв'ю для Конфлікт Зоун.
- Дякую і вам!